I have to tell you one of my other
favorite conversations and this one I I
didn't see coming I had talked to a dude
okay there was a cab driver who who's a
hair on the front of his neck connected
to the hair on the back of his neck I
want to tell you what he called it he
called it a natural turtleman
everybody huh and he said to me because
I was looking at him and he was like you
you noticed that my neck on like yeah
and he was gotta call it a natural turn
when I go huh
and so we started talking about body
here okay so then we started talking
about like single long body hairs that
you have on random parts of your body
does anyone have like one long body hair
that sticks out of a spot oh she's
waving your hand alright hear that large
weight you feel on your back is that
bust she just threw you understand you
might as well explain yourself man
where's your where's your look one long
hair right on your shoulder that's not
that crazy it isn't the same colors
have you never seen it before yeah and
it said how long do you better grow but
she's going like this yeah but if you
met a girl like that that seems like
that seems like a rebellion kind of
thing like [ __ ] you dog is logging again
my shoulder buddy I'm gonna break that
[ __ ] you know I have one I have
one I don't actually have to what I have
in my eyebrow and I in my wife hates it
somehow I never cut and we lay in bed at
night and I'll just look at her and I'll
twirl it like a supervillain
[Music]
but the other one I have and I have a I
have a long hair that comes out of my
right nostril and when I tug on it it
closes my right eye
but I think it's attached to my brain
but they may be dumber than I am
okay I'm gonna tell you the weirdest
single hair that bean counter ever had
and I told the cab driver this the
weirdest one ever had Ike there was this
girl that was dating in high school and
I was kissing her boob the first time to
wait here in this house
anyway so some it was kissing her boo
and I used to have hair down the middle
of my back and thanks for the
confirmation
here's a key okay
positive energy theorem and I really
like kissing your boob right I don't
know why I'm doing this I don't have to
I'm kissing her boo and I get one of my
hairs in my mouth so and I just I really
wanted to get rid of it so I just yeah I
got him
and she goes huh that one belongs to me
anyway it was a thick wall you know like
you like you've gonna made roof with
that hair you know like it was in the
cartoon do you want me to pull that she
goes no I think it gives me character I
was like you're wrong that he gives you
[Music]
[Music]
you